جونز ذو قيمة أجنبية يبعد مسافة طويلة عن
مسقط رأسه في لاس فيغاس، نيفادا، وهو مسعف يقوم
بتوصيل الإمدادات إلى السكان على بعد
بضع مئات من الياردات فقط من الخطوط الروسية،
يفعل ذلك، هل
يمكنك التدريب على هذا، هذا ما أفعله
من أجل العيش
هنا وأنا لا أفعل ذلك  "لا أحب المتنمرين
كثيرًا، لذا أنا سعيد لوجودي هنا والبقاء
مع الأشخاص الذين يتم الدوس عليهم،
إيلي مع مجموعة تسمى Frontline
Medics ولا يمكنك الحصول على خط أمامي أكثر بكثير
مما يشرحه هذا
الزميل المسعف كورت إريكسون من النرويج
كيف  إنهم يعملون، لدينا قائمة
بالمرضى
ولكننا لا نعرف حقًا ما
خطبهم، لذا ليس لدينا أي فكرة
قبل أن نراهم ونقوم بإجراء
مقابلتنا المختصرة
بجولة روسية واردة
[موسيقى]
في هدوء قليلاً  على مسافة أكثر أمانًا من
القتال، أوقفوا عيادتهم المتنقلة
وقدموا العلاج لمن يستطيعون،
يقول ألكسندر إن قدميه تؤلمانه، هل
يمكنك أن تسألهم عن أي قدم
لا بأس به،
فهو يعيش في شقة غير مدفأة، ويعاني من قضمة
صقيع سائلة، أعني أنه
طالما كان كذلك، فسوف يستمرون في ذلك.  خذوه إلى مستشفى
خارج باهاموت،
لم يتمكن من تركه في اللحظة التي بدأ فيها
ضيق الخناق الروسي يضيق
ببطء. القوات الروسية تكتسب أرضًا،
إنها على الأرض المرتفعة خلفي،
إنهم يتقدمون من الشمال
ويتقدمون من الجنوب.
الأسوأ من ذلك أنه لم يأت بعد، يقول إن
الجندي البريطاني المتطوع دانييل بيرك كان عليه أن
يأخذ قطعة صلبة من الشمال،
وسيحاولون القيام بحركة كماشة كبيرة
حول طيور النبق، ولا أعتقد أنهم
سيحاولون وضع دائرة حولها في حد
ذاتها.  لكن لا تذهب وتحاول تجاوزه
عبر الحقول وقطع الطريق علينا،
ومع ذلك يظل السكان في مكاننا ويفعل المتطوعون من
جميع الخطوط ما في وسعهم. تقوم فيكتوريا
لينيك بالجولات لتوزيع
الطعام والماء،
هل أنت متوتر قليلاً مع
الوضع هنا، انظر إلي، أنت
لا ترى أي
أعصاب فولاذية مع استمرار القصف